david do you think there should be a
maximum age for president like there is
a minimum age for president so
let's ignore constitutionality because
they're simply you know there's a
question as to whether you would be able
to put in a maximum age
let's imagine you could if you wanted to
and forget the constitutionality of it
so there's there's really two questions
here there's two ways we could be
thinking of a maximum age
one is we want to have some way
of limiting how long people can be in
elected office because we don't want
career
politicians so as an alternative to a
term limit you could do a maximum age
that's one reason you might want to do
it the other side is because you
genuinely think we just shouldn't have
people over a certain age doing the job
even if they're not career politicians
either because you think that after a
certain age people are less effective
less cognitively able
um or for whatever other reason you just
don't want
older people being uh president
or in some other position so if the idea
is the former which is
we just want to restrict the number of
years someone can be in elected office
to event peop
to prevent people like chuck grassley
nancy pelosi from staying in power
for so long there sort of are other ways
to deal with that
term limit is a far simpler one fixing
gerrymandering to eliminating
uh so many safe seats where once you
become the incumbent
no one from your party or another party
is going to knock you out i think that
would
would reduce how long people stay in
power
um there are some ideas that having a
sort of representative
uh system rather than just individual
first past the post
it's either one winner or not sort of
like a percentage based
system like they have in other countries
would be a way to do it i'm not so sure
about that but if the idea is just to
kind of go the direction of preventing
career politicians i think there are
simpler ways than a maximum age and
probably more palatable to the public
ways
now if your perspective is old people in
politics are just bad
remember that if the general public
overall
decided that it's a priority not to have
older people win
they could say well we're going to vote
for younger people
and you don't necessarily have to
restrict choice there
and then you get to the question of well
then why do we have a lower limit right
like if the american public genuinely
thought a 12 year old would be better
than the candidates that are adults then
they should vote for that person but
you might say most americans would
realize that that doesn't
make sense but then you remember that
they did elect trump after all so then
that makes you question anything that
relies on
the presumed intelligence of the
electorate
so i i think that if you start going
with an upper limit and saying well
you should have an upper limit that
raises questions of why do we have
limits at all if it's really just about
letting the american people decide on
the best candidates
i think it's sort of tough uh along
those lines
the bigger question to me if the aspect
of this that's most concerning is a
cognitive issue
is the possibility of saying here we're
gonna put in place three or four
different
requirements that would include if you
want to have something like the montreal
cognitive assessment you have it but
maybe something else as well
i'm not against it in principle i think
that it does get back to the issue of
constitutionality and pragmatics because
it'll just never happen i mean
look i would like to have a president
imagine for a second and that this is
completely anti-constitutional
it's and it in a sense it's
authoritarian because you're imposing
limits that that could be even misused
in some way against
uh certain sectors of the population but
imagine if to be
a major you know to be a party nominee
or whatever democrats and republicans
and why would they do it or
or the constitution put in place a rule
which said
you've got to do a montreal cognitive
assessment you need to do a psych eval
the results of which will be published
publicly
and if there's personality disorders or
whatever it's going to be there
you have to do a basic on the spot like
basic american history
and constitutionality not to the point
of like you have the knowledge of a
constitutional lawyer but just really
basic things about history
uh who who were the uh allies
uh and the axis of evil in uh world war
ii where you know there's really simple
things
many candidates would immediately be
humiliated or they would actually have
to study and take it seriously and we
would end up with more informed
candidates
that's super interesting to me although
i think there's an authoritarian aspect
to it and i don't think there's any way
that it happens constitutionally so
the answer to should there be an upper
age limit my question to you is
what is the goal is it to prevent career
politicians
is it to ensure that our elected
officials are cognitively capable
is it because you just don't think for
whatever reason
that the country should be led by people
above a certain age depending on your
answers to those questions
the approach that could be taken varies
pretty dramatically and i'd be
interested in hearing from you about
that
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set spending limits you
can freeze them
you can delete them anytime you want so
when you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be because you
can destroy
the virtual card number right after
using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at
privacy.com pacman